finalement elle déposera plainte et
l'agresseur va reconnaître les faits peu
de temps après seul il traque
[Musique]
présenter un juge pour enfants il est
actuellement sous contrôle judiciaire
dans un foyer pour mineur
mardi 17 juillet
hôpital de la conception à Marseille
au service réanimation nous allons
rencontrer Louis un grand-père de 83 ans
qui vient de frôler la mort après avoir
été agressé
il a été roué de coup par un jeune homme
ce qui a provoqué une hémorragie
cérébrale l'agresseur lui a arraché son
collier en or son petit-fils venait à
peine de partir
et comme il rentre dans le couloir et un
jeune dedans il lui dit excusez-moi il
est passé le facteur et mon grand-père
il lui dit je vais ouvrir la boîte aux
lettres je vais regarder si le facteur
est passé comme ici tourné
des vrais hommes quoi 85 ans
et puis je me retrouve pour pouvoir me
donner un coup de poing et après il est
parti je l'ai couru j'ai couru derrière
juste deux trois mètres et je suis tombé
encore et m'a filé encore un coup d'eau
un coup de pied
lui est né à Marseille en 1929 une ville
dans laquelle il s'est longtemps senti
en sécurité
que vous alliez vous faire arracher le
colis
aujourd'hui Louis est sorti de l'hôpital
il souffre de fortes migraines Louis et
loin d'être la seule victime des
arracheurs de collier
nous nous sommes procurés des images de
vidéosurveillance cette première scène
se déroule dans un bus
[Musique]
les agresseurs font preuve d'une rare
violence celui-ci saisit le sac d'un
vieil homme avant de s'en prendre à son
collier
d'après la police
840 arrachage de colliers ont été
recensés à Marseille depuis le mois de
juin jusqu'à 30 par jour ici trois
jeunes entrent dans un bus pour arracher
le collier du chauffeur
pourquoi ces agressions se
multiplient-elles quels sont les
filières de recelles quel lien ces
nouveaux délinquants entretiennent
des cités marseillaises
[Musique]
Marseille et la ville française qui a vu
apparaître le phénomène de la rachage en
2010 c'est aussi ma ville natale je veux
comprendre comment cette violence a pu
émerger brutalement ces 10 dernières
années plusieurs milliards d'euros ont
été investis dans la rénovation de la
ville mais la délinquance persiste
d'après la préfecture les vols avec
violence ont baissé de 2 et demi pour
cent en 2012 mais cela représente pas
moins de 6000 fées
commissariat de Bougainville dans les
quartiers nord
j'ai obtenu l'autorisation de tourner
avec une brigade spécialisée qui traque
les arracheurs
vient de sévir
il a été interpellé en flagrant délit
par la BAC
la brigade spécialisée part en renfort
voilà
on peut avoir plus d'informations
concernant ce vol
l'auteur présumé du vol est menotté dans
la voiture
la victime choquée a disparu
on voit les deux gonzesses on voit lui
arracher le collier donc du coup le
collègue ont suivi de le tour on arrive
des Pyrénées j'ai oublié des Pyrénées on
est tombé
pour t'arranger les histoires tu as mis
où la chaîne la chaîne que tu as arraché
de la fille la chaîne ça c'est pas moi
ça ils t'ont vu les policiers tu l'as
mis où
c'est bon elle est là elle est là elle
est là
nickel
[__]
avec la chaîne et l'interpellation en
flagrant délit les policiers ont assez
d'éléments pour placer le jeune homme en
garde à vue appelons le Sammy il est
immigré clandestin il dit avoir 14 ans
Sami est conduit au commissariat de
Noailles sur la Canebière dans le centre
ville
[Applaudissements]
et la journée est loin d'être terminée
pour les policiers il n'est 11h et déjà
5 arrachages de collier viennent d'être
commis à Marseille
de dans le nord de dans le centre
pendant qu'on était sur interpellation
il y a eu encore un autre un arraché bon
ça n'arrête pas c'est vraiment le gros
fluo actuellement sur Marseille
jade est enquêtrice bonjour
c'est elle qui va entendre le suspect
bonjour
ben tu me parles en français là
tu habites où
tu sais pas où tu habites allez on y va
malgré le flagrant délit celui que nous
avons appelé Sami vanille et les fées
donc là tu as été attrapé pour un vol de
collier
comment ça non c'est pas toi
pourquoi il te faut une victime pour
dire que tu as arraché un collier tu as
compris pourquoi tu me dis elle est où
la victime
quand tu veux tu comprends
donc à côté de 13h20 tu es en garde à
vue pour voir avec violence
oui arracher un collier c'est un vol
avec violence en l'absence de la victime
le suspect espère sans doute qu'il sera
libéré rapidement ils essaient de savoir
ce qu'on a contre eux avant de
de donner leur version ils inverse les
rôles mais la victime va finalement se
signaler au commissariat une femme de 50
ans encore sous le choc
bonjour je vous ai vu votre téléphone
tout à l'heure vous êtes le mari
je me suis fait agresser
rapidos j'ai même pas vu venir c'est
après je me suis aperçu que je me suis
adressée c'est tout
30 secondes même pas vous êtes blessé
dans cette ascenseur ça me croise un
autre arracheur présumé
il a 20 ans il vit à peine de sortir de
prison pour trafic de stupéfiant
appelons-le il y a
les policiers lui reprochent d'avoir
commis pas moins de 20 arrachages de
colliers en un seul mois contrairement à
celui que nous avons appelé Sami lui a
avoué les faits
à l'étage la victime reconnaît
formellement Sami mais elle hésite à
déposer plainte
pourquoi vous dites que ça sert à rien
si personne signale à la police ce qui
se passe
voilà finalement elle déposera plainte
et l'agresseur va reconnaître les faits
peu de temps après seul il traque
[Musique]
présenter un juge pour enfants il est
actuellement sous contrôle judiciaire
dans un foyer pour mineur
ce n'est pas le cas de celui que nous
avons appelé Elias il doit retirer ses
lacets lui ce qui l'attend c'est la
comparution immédiate avant cela il a
rendez-vous avec le vice procureur
[Musique]
Deezer du matin cette camionnette que
les policiers surnomme la charrette des
postes tous les garder à vue de la
veille au tribunal correctionnel de
Marseille
des braqueurs des dealers présumés qui
se moquent des petits arracheurs
avant de recevoir Elias le vice
procureur j'attends un dernier coup
d’œil à son dossier à Marseille le parka
décrété la tolérance zéro vis-à-vis des
arracheurs de collier tout ce qui nous
inquiète plus c'est la violence en fait
qui est utilisée à l'égard des victimes
qui est plus est sans traumatisés parce
qu'ils ont vécu avec toujours des
incapacités temporaires de travail par
exemple aujourd'hui dans ce dossier
l'une des victimes puisque on a deux a
quand même 10 jours d'un capacité pourra
de travail cette victime je l'ai
rencontré elle ne sort plus de chez elle
depuis l'agression elle témoigne un
visage caché de peur d'être reconnu par
son agresseur comme Louis l'homme de 83
ans que j'avais interview à l'hôpital
elle m'assure qu'elle a cru vivre ces
derniers instants
beaucoup on a entendu quelqu'un qui
criait qui arrivait par derrière d'une
manière assez violente il m'a sauté au
cou je me suis pas laissée faire et à
partir de là quand il a vu qu'il n'y
arrivait pas et il m'a fait tomber par
terre en arrière et il a commencé à me
tirer donc par les cheveux par la tête
il m'a il m'a tiré le long du sol quand
j'ai vu qu'il allait me taper il me
fracasser le crâne contre le sol là je
dis ça va ça va c'est bon c'est bon il a
arraché la chaîne il est parti ça
terrorise
c'est à dire que on dort très mal
ensuite dans la rue sans arrêt lorsqu'il
y a quelqu'un me sert un peu de trop
près je fais que me retourner je suis un
état de panique j'ai mon cœur qui se met
à battre très très fort c'est très
difficile à vivre
retour au tribunal le vice procureur va
faire comprendre suspect qu'il risque de
retourner en prison
allez entrer Ahmed chaper connu pour son
intransigeance
je vois que franchement vous vous allez
droit au mur là
sortir parce que quand même c'est
intrigant en réalité vous avez 20 ans
c'est à dire que vous êtes très jeune
avec 12 condamnations quasi judiciaires
excuses du peu
ple
et moi vous n'êtes victimes que de
vous-même il faut il faut en fait être
conscient que si vous commentez vous
commettez des infractions vous allez
vous allez être sanctionner
personnellement vous devez payer la
facture
et vous voulez quoi on vous donne une
médaille vous voulez qu'on vous donne
les médailles jeune homme
vous n'avez pas pris conscient du fait
que c'est extrêmement grave
le traumatisme que vous occasionnez aux
victimes de fait de coller et
considérable est-ce que vous est-ce que
vous comprenez ça monsieur il est
considérable considérable
tu as peur de la prison c'est normal
et après c'est normal que vous faites
plus grave jugé en comparution immédiate
le jour même
ce jeune homme que nous avons appelé
Ilias a été condamné à 3 ans de prison
ferme
qui sont ces arracheurs de colliers
pourquoi sont-ils prêts à tout pour
mettre la main sur quelques grammes d'or
j'ai voulu aller à leur rencontre dans
leur quartier mais il est difficile de
les approcher ma caméra n'est pas la
bienvenue
à proximité des bars HLM
ces jeunes en scooter entreprennent de
nous intimider
je décide de revenir plus tard le temps
de trouver un guide
en attendant c'est en suivant les
policiers dans leurs enquêtes que je
vais revoir de jeunes arracheurs
merci Ali dirige le groupe vol violence
il est sur le point d'arrêter une bande
très organisée
en ce moment on travaille sur un deux
roues avec deux individus dessus ils ont
arraché avant-hier ils ont fait trois
victimes et la semaine dernière trois
victimes encore
bon on a tout normalement
l'arracheur présumait a été reconnu par
ses victimes sur cette série de photos
appelons-le Mika
6h du matin allier son équipe parte
interpeller me cacher lui
[Musique]
il vit dans cet immeuble
25 mètres carrés où vivent 4 personnes
dans une grande promiscuité
[Musique]
le suspect n'est pas chez lui
on vient de sortir
bon ben on l'a pas trouvé au domicile
apparemment il est encore dehors donc là
on va procéder un perquisition son frère
est majeur donc il va assister à la
perquisition il va signer avec nous le
procès-verbal les policiers fouillent
l'appartement à la recherche de preuves
il ne trouveront pas de collier en or
mais sur le toit
touche pas ouais touche pas avec les
mails
un peu trop
on va dire que si elle se défend un peu
trop et je crois que tu es au fond tu as
un couteau aussi
6h30 du matin la mère de Mika rentre du
travail
je suis pas contre la loi je suis pour
parce que j'aime pas quelqu'un qui
m'arrache une chaîne ou bien que d'être
jugée
pas pour moi je vais pas pour les autres
elle élève seule ses enfants elle semble
désemparée par les agissements de son
fils aîné
[Musique]
c'est la mer à 6h elle était déjà dehors
elle est partie travailler et puis
pendant qu'elle est partie il y a
quelqu'un qui a dû la contacter pour lui
dire qu'il y avait
la police chez elle pour faire une
perquisition donc elle est revenue en
panique on la voit les paniquée
elle cherche à gagner sa vie honnêtement
mais bon derrière il y a un de ses fils
qui fait des conneries et derrière c'est
tout le monde qui mord quoi
deux heures plus tard celui que nous
appelons Mika est arrêté il est
transféré au commissariat de Noailles
sur la Canebière
pour tenter d'obtenir ses aveux les
policiers le placent en garde à vue dans
le cadre de trois procédures pour vol à
l'arrachée et d'un cambriolage
jade va organiser ce qu'on appelle un
tapissage
par
contre une présentation victime de
l'auteur présumé derrière une glace sans
teint
objectif obtenir une confirmation
définitive
[Musique]
la deuxième victime le reconnaît aussi
voilà tournez-vous sur la gauche
malgré tout le suspect persiste à nier
les faits il demande une confrontation
avec les victimes de Nantes elle accepte
un moment très rare que nous avons pu
filmer entre le mise en cause et de des
victimes
donc Madame est-ce que vous maintenez
vos déclarations
donc à savoir que l'individu est si
présent et bien l'auteur de
déclarations
[Musique]
mais là c'est pas moi c'est pas moi
je vais aller frapper des femmes
Mika sera condamné à 30 mois de prison
ferme les victimes elles expriment une
peur j'ai peur pour plus tard j'ai peur
à partir d'ici alors pour vous dire je
suis né ici je vais être obligé de
partir
[Musique]
quand les auteurs présumés n'avaient pas
les faits les policiers peuvent parfois
s'appuyer sur la vidéo surveillance
140 caméras films en permanence les rues
de Marseille
on voit trois jeunes arrivés grâce à
elle Ali le policier a pu étudier le
mode opératoire des voleurs pour essayer
de repérer des victimes potentielles
ces trois garçons sont mineurs
regardez bien le jeune homme au t-shirt
rose
c'est au dernier moment qui va s'en
prendre à cette passante et lui a
arraché son collier
[Musique]
la victime n'a pas le temps de réagir
les voleurs prennent la fuite
l'enquêteur alli les arrêtera le
lendemain
je tente une fois de plus de rencontrer
ces arracheurs de collier
[Musique]
c'est par l'intermédiaire de Saïd un
ancien braqueur repenti que je vais
pouvoir les interviewer
il me donne rendez-vous dans le
troisième arrondissement de Marseille
dans certains quartiers le chômage des
jeunes dépasserait les 50%
Saïd est aujourd'hui commercial pour un
groupe de hip-hop
[Musique]
il vend des t-shirts et a repris des
études les bêtises dit-il c'est derrière
lui grâce au bon Dieu ben j'essaie de me
réinsérer rentrer dans la ligne de
droite passer mon diplôme et voilà
j'espère que j'espère que tout va bien
se passer à l'extérieur du magasin Saïd
repère de jeunes arracheurs qu'il
connaît ils ont entre 15 et 19 ans tous
en échec scolaire sans la moindre
hésitation ils vont m'expliquer comment
ils opèrent à deux sur un scooter
tout simplement
c'est simple c'est ça l'argent très
facile
à l'abri des regards l'arracheur nous
montre son butin du jour 500 euros
l'argent de ce qu'il appelle le zélérate
à Marseille
[Musique]
il tombe il meurt
ce sera le destin
d'autres arracheurs se greffent à la
conversation je vais comprendre pourquoi
ce qu'ils appellent le zeldra
l'arrachage de colliers et devenu leur
sport favori
[Musique]
phénomène quoi et ouais c'est ça tous
les jeunes tous les jeunes du quartier
il est toujours tous apparence
de la violence du geste moi allez on
passe pas ça l'argent mais
on peut des fois on préfère le faire
avec plus de délicatesse mais après ça
on voit que la personne
de quelle façon la violence
avant c'était le téléphone et tout
maintenant ça marche plus avec l'or et
tout avec des chaînes en or et tout
certains arracheurs marseillais
affirment gagner jusqu'à 3000 euros par
jour
pas de voleur sans receleur
à Marseille comme ailleurs en France la
loi vient de changer
depuis un an les bijoutiers sont tenus
de racheter l'or quand leur présente par
chèque ou virement bancaire les
transactions laissent désormais des
traces alors des receleurs ambulants
sont apparus ils opèrent en pleine rue
et ils achètent cash pendant 2 mois Ali
le policier et son groupe les ont
photographies
un peu partout dans la rue et puis là
d'un coup là il y a un individu qui
arrive apparemment pour leur proposer
quelque chose à vendre
c'est receleurs ont été arrêtés il
rachetait l'or aux arracheurs 10 fois
moins cher que nos l'aurait fait un
bijoutier on va donc là il est en train
de lui remettre un collier on le voit
bien il est épais en plus
là il passe le bijou à son collègue là
qu'il oppose là-dessus on le voit là qui
tient le l'objet dans sa main droite
c'est une balance ou quoi là pour peser
pendant que lui vérifie autre chose
la qualité de l'or pour voir si c'est de
l'or ou non et par rapport aux bijoutier
comment est vendu l'or ici
alors par exemple un collier comme ça
bon il est vraiment épais là il peut se
négocier autour de 500 600 euros
et normalement un collier comme ça et
souvent facilement
4000 euros
vous avez une idée
alors là il y a enfin il y a une partie
qui doit partir certainement
chez les bijoutiers de du secteur qui
connaissent très bien une partie à mon
avis qui doit qui doit partir au Maghreb
que devient l'ordre d'écoliers arrachés
ou les receleurs échangent-ils leurs
acquisitions contre de l'argent content
pour poursuivre l'enquête et remonter la
filière je quitte Marseille et me rend
au Maroc
Casablanca la capitale économique du
pays c'est ici que certains receleurs
revendraient les colliers arrachés au
Maroc plus encore qu'en Europe le marché
de l'or connaît une flambée sans
précédent le gramme se négocie jusqu'à
48 euros deux fois plus qu'en France
selon nos informations la revente des
colliers se fait dans ce marché
muni d'une caméra cachée je me rends
dans une échoppe avec deux chaînes en or
dont j'ai cassé le fermoir afin de
laisser croire qu'elles ont été volées
tu as reçu ah non j'ai pas de reçu
ils viennent de France mais d'où
tu en as combien là j'en ai deux c'est
tout ah non j'en ai d'autres 10 15
donne-moi ce que tu as allez je t'en
rapporte 10
écoute je peux faire affaire avec toi
oui et en France je peux m'en procurer
un kilo si tu veux d'accord
un kilo d'or que ce bijoutier se dit
prêt à m'acheter 30 000 euros je repars
en prétextant un délai de réflexion
un peu plus loin une autre échoppe ce
vendeur n'est pas non plus très
regardant sur la provenance des colliers
1900 soit pas moins de 690 euros pour
mes deux chaînes avec la facture
toute façon ça va à la casse
on va les fondre
après les avoir fondu on en fait
d'autres bijoux on les fait poinçonner
par la douane et on les met en vitrine
de nombreux bijoux de cette vitrine sont
peut-être issus de colliers arrachés à
Marseille et refondu à Casablanca
les autres écoute rassemble moi tout ce
que tu as et reviens me voir pour qu'on
conclure l'affaire
arracheur receleur bijoutier
trois étapes pour un trafic qui s'avère
de plus en plus rentable
retour à Marseille les arracheurs vivent
souvent dans les mêmes cités que les
petits caïdes qui contrôlent le trafic
de drogue
sont-ils liés je me rends avec Saïd le
braqueur repenti dans la cité où il est
né rien à dire Frais Vallon est l'un des
quartiers les plus sensibles de
Marseille
sans l'ami d'enfance de Saïd maliano
nous n'aurions jamais pu filmer ici
c'est une caméra est bien seule après
voilà je fais canarder
en guise de bienvenue sur ce qu'ils
appellent leur territoire les jeunes du
quartier nous ont préparé une parade et
font ronfler les moteurs
je demande à Saïd et maliano si
l'arrachage de bijoux n'est pas une
première étape dans le parcours d'un
délinquant
en vérité c'est simple en vérité c'est
simple ça va se faire en cinq six mois
pas plus tu commences par quoi je
commence à arracher comme ils étaient à
l'heure les alarmes je commence à
arracher les chaînes dès que tu as
racheter les chiens tu vois que c'est je
crois que c'est du gâteau tu commences à
vendre vu que tu as vu dès qu'il y avait
une démarche je commence à bande de la
poudre tu vois la poudre je commence à
voir que l'argent je commence à voir que
l'argent ça se fait je vais te dire je
commence à avoir sa rentrée un peu moins
et tu montes sur les bras colos le
Braquo c'est une source sûre tu vois
après une fois que tu as fait ça après
la catégorie dessus je vous laisse je
vous laisse ce soir vous expliquer une
fois qu'on a fait tout ça parce que là
parce que le saumon tu vois une fois que
tu as fait tout une fois que tu as fait
ces cinq trucs tu arrives au bras con
après c'est une étape
tu vois mais déjà rien que sa solution
après la conversation va prendre une
autre dimension l'ami de Saïd me parle
de règlement de compte liés au trafic de
drogue cela même qui ont fait 15 morts
depuis le début de l'année et qui donne
à Marseille son visage sombre et violent
quand tu fais de l'argent sale
exemple
de là-bas
il commence à péter un blanc il commence
à me voler mes clients je sors un
exemple moi je veux dire comment ça me
va mes clients de là voilà ça part de là
allez
et maintenant comme ça circuit des mains
dans cette enquête j'ai découvert que
l'arrachage de colliers le trafic de
drogue était deux business bien
différents mais les arracheurs la
plupart mineurs risquent de basculer
dans le grand banditisme en attendant
certains jeunes des quartiers luttent
contre cette fatalité
place Jean Jaurès au cœur de Marseille
le terrain de prédilection des
arracheurs
je rencontre les batata un collectif de
rappeurs qui a écrit un morceau sur
l'arrachage de colliers
[Musique]
savent de quoi il parle certains sont
d'anciens arracheurs beaucoup ont fait
de la prison quelques-uns sont encore
sous contrôle judiciaire tous se sont
rangés grâce à la passion du rap
on incite les jeunes à s'en sortir c'est
ça c'est ça regardez il y a des preuves
façon il y a des mecs de la rue qui
réussissent il y a des comme des
rappeurs des footballeurs des boxeurs
des médecins des avocats des touts
là on va aller voir soprano ce soir
laisse battants ont rendez-vous avec une
voix célèbre du rap marseillais Saïd du
soprano
une star qui fait figure d'exemples à
suivre pour ces jeunes en marge de leur
rencontre je décide de les faire réagir
sur l'agression de Louis le grand-père
rouet de coup pour un collier en or je
vais vous montrer quelque chose est-ce
que pour une perte de basket on peut en
arriver là
aucune valeur qu'ils ont fait ça ils ont
pas de principe pas de valeur
passer un vieux
faut être il faut sortir d'acheter ou
c'est pas même tu sors de l'hôpital
psychiatrique tu fais pas ça pourquoi
pour une paire de baskets 150 euros 200
euros
c'est n'importe quoi
nous cautionne pas ça on n'aime pas les
gens comme ça ça peut être mon père
ça peut être ma mère et ça qu'elle soit
blanche que soit noir qu'elle soit
arabes c'est pareil on s'en fout si tu
fais ça c'est comme ça veut dire tiens
pas ta mère tiens pas ton père tu
n'aimes pas tu vois ce que je veux te
dire ça veut dire tu es capable de
cracher la figure de ton père ou ta mère
ou même le père de ton meilleur pote et
on espère vraiment que ça s'arrête déjà
nous
à Marseille on souffre beaucoup
c'est le dernier jour de mon reportage
dans ma ville natale
[Musique]
une marche silencieuse est organisée en
hommage à Julien un jeune homme de 26
ans tabassé à mort pour avoir regardé le
travers un autre jeune de sa cité
les rappeurs se joignent au cortège en
tête des femmes pour la plupart des
mères de famille
certaines ont perdu un délai
la maman de Julien ne parvient pas à
contenir sa douleur
[Musique]
je termine ce tournage avec un sentiment
de malaise la violence celle des
arracheurs de colliers celle des petits
caïdes et celles des gangsters
cette violence est sur le point de
devenir ordinaire
[Musique]